- It's a great pleasure to be here.
It's a wonderful experience of a lifetime
to be a Radcliffe fellow.
I'd like to thank Dean Liz Cohen.
I'd like to thank Associate Dean Judy Vichniac,
all the staff at the Radcliffe for the wonderful
work that they do to keep us safe and happy
through the year.
I'd like to thank my fellow fellows that have
also given me such a good ride through this
year.
And I'd like to thank the people with whom
I've been working this year, in particular
at the lab of Any Knoll in Earth and planetary
sciences, Andy himself and his lab, in particular,
Elizabeth Sibert, who's a Harvard fellow,
who's been working with me during this year,
teaching me about new things.
And also my Radcliffe research partner, Hannah
[? Burn, ?] who has been working together
with a post-doc in my lab in Paris to move
forward with some of our work.
So there's many people I'd like to thank.
Also, Dan Needleman in molecular cell biology
here, who has been a great inspiration to
me too.
So with that, let's dive into the ocean.
So I'd like us to think about the ocean for
the next hour or so.
I'd like to think about our planet ocean.
I think we all appreciate that the ocean occupies
more than 70% of the surface of the Earth.
And we look at it, and I think we all appreciate
that it's huge, that it's awesome, that it's
powerful.
Right?
But when we think about how does it connect
to us, how does it connect to our daily lives,
it's maybe a bit more abstract to bring the
ocean into that intimacy with ourselves.
So let's go back to the very beginning.
Let's go back to the stromatolites, the fossilized
remains of the very first cyanobacteria, as
far as we know.
And it's within these organisms that this
incredible machinery called photosynthesis
first evolved.
In my opinion, this is perhaps the greatest
evolution, the greatest invention of evolution
that we know about that evolved very early
on and performs incredibly important things.
If we think about it for a second, what photosynthesis
does is it converts light energy into chemical
energy.
OK?
That's what we try to do when we generate
energy out of solar energy.
When We're not very good at it yet.
We're getting better.
But the plants and photosynthetic organisms
do this incredibly well by generating chemical
energy that can be utilized in different ways
from sunlight, from the energy in sunlight.
Photosynthesis also converts carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere into organic materials.
So everything, including ourselves, we are
all built from this organic materials.
We are literally what we eat.
All of that organic material comes ultimately
from primary production generated through
photosynthesis by the conversion of carbon
dioxide into organic materials.
And then, photosynthesis splits water to generate
oxygen, which, of course, we and many of our
co-inhabitants of our planet also breathe.
So it was a remarkable invention of evolution
that really changed the history of our planet
and permitted life on Earth to really evolve
as to how we know it today.
Here, we see the evolutionary record of life
on Earth, beginning in the Archean, sort of
3 and 1/2 billion years or so ago, where we
have the first evolution of oxygenic photosynthesis
within the cyanobacteria that formed ultimately
these stromatolites.
And this started generating whiffs of oxygen.
So there was no oxygen on Earth before life
first evolved.
Right?
And then, finally, these whiffs of oxygen
began to be generated, ultimately leading
to what we know as the Great Oxidation Event.
And then, slowly, as oxygen began to stabilize,
still at pretty low levels, not yet at today's
levels, then we see the evolution of different
forms of life that were very likely stimulated
by the photosynthetic processes.
So the first reactions that we know of are
coming from organisms such as the cyanobacteria,
which later on, following the increase in
oxygen, gave rise to more complex eukaryotic
cells, which are cells like our own cells,
which contain DNA packaged inside the nucleus,
which have mitochondria to generate energy
inside them and so forth.
So this is the great, first innovation that
was likely permitted by evolution, by photosynthesis
in the first place.
And then, as these eukaryotes continue to
evolve, they were still single-celled.
OK?
They ultimately gave rise to photosynthetic
eukaryotes.
These eukaryotic cells learn how to do photosynthesis
by acquiring cyanobacteria and incorporating
cyanobacteria inside those cells.
And then, following the evolution of these
first photosynthetic eukaryotes, we likely
had another bump in oxygen up to pretty much
modern day levels of around 20%, which then
permitted the evolution of multicellular life,
the evolution of more complex life forms,
most notably in the Cambrian Explosion, where
all kinds of weird and wonderful multicellular
organisms first appeared in the fossil record.
And then, we have a third moment, when photosynthesis
appears to be particularly important, which
is the evolution of land plants, multicellular
organisms that can photosynthesize beginning
to colonize the land.
We have another bump of oxygen, going up to
sort of 30% here.
And this likely permitted the evolution of
giant insects, of giant animals up to dinosaurs
and so on.
And then, indeed, these levels finally went
back down again to modern day levels of about
20%, fortunately.
Otherwise, we may be living with these giant
insects and animals even today.
So here we see that the history of life on
Earth was very much permitted by photosynthesis
and very much enabled by different evolutionary
events that had happened in the ocean.
So life evolved in the ocean.
We're pretty certain of that.
And through different aspects, we now know
that the ocean very much sustains life on
our planet for all kinds of different organisms.
And in our own particular way, for ourselves,
the ocean protects us.
It protects us by feeding us, providing us
with fish, and so on.
It protects us by absorbing excess heat, by
absorbing carbon dioxide in the atmosphere.
Without the ocean, the temperature of our
planet would be even higher than it is today.
And the ocean also generates oxygen through
these photosynthetic organisms that are present.
The ocean, finally, is also a resource in
many different ways, not only for tourism,
also for desalination, extraction of minerals,
all kinds of different resources that we know
are important.
And we sort of tend to think that the ocean
is so big, it can sort of absorb whatever
we throw at it.
Right?
But in fact, that's not true.
If you take all of the water that is in the
ocean, and you bring it all together into
one single drop sitting on top of a dry Earth,
you begin to see how little water we actually
have.
And the majority of this is ocean water.
And it's really very, very little.
If we look at fresh water, it's a little drop
of water sitting on top of the ocean water,
the salt water that you probably can't see
at the back.
So the ocean is really not as big as we think.
We're throwing all kinds of insults at it,
but it can only withstand a certain amount.
And we know today that the ocean is very much
under pressure.
It's under pressure in several different ways.
On the one hand, through the increase in temperature
in the atmosphere, due to greenhouse gases
that are present in the atmosphere, are causing
increases in the temperature of the ocean.
The increase in atmospheric carbon dioxide
is mixing with water.
And that simple reaction of carbon dioxide
plus water produces carbonate, produces bicarbonate,
which are acids.
And so the oceans are slowly acidifying in
a pretty dramatic way.
And then through phenomena that we don't really
understand, the oceans are also losing their
oxygen.
There is a process of de-oxygenation that
has been observed in many locations around
the world.
So this is a sort of third insult that is
happening to the ocean collectively.
And in a global context, we can see the increase
of sea levels caused by the melting of the
glaciers that are affecting coastal ecosystems.
We have effects on coral reefs caused by acidification
of the ocean, and so on.
So the ocean is very much feeling the pressure
of we, of humanity today.
So it's in this context that we really launched
this expedition called Tara Oceans, back in
2009.
And what we wanted to do here was to sort
of get an idea of the state of the ocean at
the beginning of the 21st century, because
nobody's ever done this before.
We don't really have a zero time point for
the state of the ocean.
So we set out to do this project way back
in 2009.
And we specifically wanted to study the state
of marine ecosystems, in particular the microscopic
plankton that I'll introduce you to in a second.
And we were very much inspired by previous
expeditions as well, learning from the past
to try to move forward, standing on the shoulders
of giants, people who had done this sort of
thing before.
And here are a couple of examples of previous
expeditions that I'm sure you have heard of,
certainly this one on the HMS Beagle from
1831 to 1836.
There were two particular gentlemen on board
here, Captain Robert Fitzroy.
He was the captain of the ship.
And his job was to map out the coastlines
of the different countries that they travelled
around.
This is South America.
And you see he did a fantastic job doing this
work on this expedition.
But he was also very much a scientist in his
own right.
In those days, scientists didn't exist.
They were called natural philosophers.
And I think that describes very much who these
kinds of people were.
And in the case of Fitzroy, he went on to
develop what we now call the storm barometer,
which is a remarkable invention to allow us
to predict the weather based on the atmospheric
pressure to know when it's going to rain or
when it's going to be fine.
So he developed that during his lifetime.
Also on board this expedition, there was the
young Charles Darwin.
And I'm sure he needs no introduction as to
what he achieved in his lifetime in providing
us with a theory for the origin of species
and mechanisms of evolution and so on.
And then, there's the second example that
I want to talk about briefly, which is the
HMS Challenger expedition.
This was performed about 50 years later, 1872
to '76.
This was performed by Thompson and Murray.
And they went out over five-year expedition.
You can see where they went here to basically
test the idea that was prevalent at that time
that there was no life in the ocean below
the surface layers, below where the light
can penetrate.
It was believed at that time that the ocean
was azoic, devoid of life.
So they went out on this expedition.
And they dredged and pulled up all kinds of
incredible organisms to show that yes, indeed,
there is life at these depths of the ocean.
And many of these samples were subsequently
taken by this guy called Ernst Haeckel, who
is a German.
He was really very much a natural philosopher
in the sense that he was sort of half scientist
and half artist.
And he generated these incredible images of
these microscopic organisms that he was observing
in his very primitive microscope that ultimately
gave rise to the movement of Art Nouveau,
very much inspired this whole idea of living
forms being used to create new architectural
forms.
This is the World Expo in Paris in I think
1902.
You can see the Eiffel Tower back here.
This doesn't exist anymore, sadly.
But you can see how it was very much inspired
by these microscopic life forms that were
drawn by Haeckel.
Haeckel was also the father of ecology.
He coined the term "ecology," which has now
become obviously a formal science in itself.
And this movement of architecture of Art Nouveau
subsequently continues today through organic
architecture, which we see many examples around.
So we see how life continues to inspire beyond
the science itself of studying life on Earth.
So these were the sorts of inspirations that
we got from our project, for initiating the
Tara Oceans project.
And what we specifically wanted to study in
this project were the planktonic organisms,
which we can consider as sort of the invisible
multitude.
When you think about life in the ocean, I'm
sure you don't think about plankton.
You think about sharks and whales and so on.
But in fact, the plankton, these microscopic
organisms that drift with the currents, really
do represent the majority of life in the ocean.
They're at least 50% of the biomass of life
in the ocean, probably considerably much more
than that.
And they consist of all kinds of different
organisms of different shapes and sizes that
you can see in this mandala that I'll introduce
you to in a second.
And these organisms have all kinds of very
important functions.
They are the base of the oceanic food chains
that lead up to the fish and the larger organisms.
The photosynthetic component of the plankton,
just like plants on land, they sequester carbon
dioxide out of the atmosphere.
And they bring it into organic materials in
the ocean.
Through photosynthesis, they also generate
the oxygen that is so important for us and
many other organisms.
And because the ocean is deep, some of these
organisms, when they die, they will sink to
the bottom of the ocean.
And they'll take the carbon that they have
produced, the organic carbon, they'll take
it with them all the way to the bottom of
the ocean, effectively taking carbon out of
the carbon cycle on the surface of the Earth,
sequestering it for geological periods of
time that can ultimately form the fossil fuels
that we're so avidly burning today.
And we know through studies from many people
around the world, including also many eminent
scientists in Harvard, that the plankton,
on the one hand, can affect the climate.
They've affected climate of the Earth during
the history of life on Earth in several different
ways.
And we know also that these organisms are
affected by climate change.
So there's a kind of feedback between the
two, between climate and planktonic organisms,
such that plankton are really at the very
heart of the climate machine that regulates
the climate system of the planet.
So what's in the plankton then?
You can see this mandala here of nice little
organisms.
But let's go and dig a little deeper.
And let me introduce you to the different
kinds of organisms that are present.
I'll start with these guys that we call the
protists.
These are cells that consist of eukaryotic
features, just like our own cells.
The difference is that these guys are single
celled.
Typically, they exist as single cells.
Sometimes, they will form chains, as you see
here.
And you see they have different kinds of shapes
and sizes.
Each one of these cells is between 100th and
1/10 of a millimeter in size, I would say.
Some of them have structures like little pillboxes,
like you see here.
Some of them look like little spaceships,
all kinds of weird and wonderful shapes.
Some of these are photosynthetic.
Some of them parasitize other organisms.
Some of them eat organic material like we
do.
And if we add all of these up together, in
an average liter of seawater, we can find
up to 10 million of these organisms in that
volume of water.
So these are the protists.
On top of the protists, we have what we call
the zooplankton.
These are, again, different kinds of shapes
and sizes that generally tend to be bigger.
And these are the grazers in the ocean.
These are the cows and the sheep of the oceans
that go around eating typically those protist
organisms that I showed you in the previous
slide.
And these can be present at up to 100 individuals
in an average liter of seawater.
And then, getting smaller, we've got the prokaryotic
organisms, the bacteria, the archaea, which
can be present at up to a billion cells in
an average liter of sea water.
Some of these are photosynthetic.
Some of them are related to those initial
cyanobacteria that gave rise to the origins
of oxygen on Earth.
And then, even smaller than the bacteria and
archaea, we have the viruses and the giant
viruses, which, again, are all kinds of different
weird shapes.
And these can be present at up to 10 billion
individuals per liter of seawater.
These are not pathogenic for us.
But the role of these guys is to infect the
other components of the plankton to essentially
ensure that there is equilibrium in the ecosystems.
If one organism tries to takeoff, tries to
go too strongly, a virus will show up to cut
it down, to ensure that equilibrium is maintained.
So I sort of consider these organisms as like
the lubricators of the ecosystem to ensure
that excesses are not tolerated and to ensure
that evolution moves forward, as organisms
adapt.
So we have all of these organisms that are
present in ocean water and that are present
in different amounts.
And they're also present very much in different
sizes.
What you see here is a video of a zooplankton,
the large shrimp-like organism called the
copepod with a diatom sitting on top of it,
this round cell here, which is one of the
protists.
That's the diatom here.
And then sitting on top of the diatom is a
bacterial cell here.
So we're going through several orders of magnitude
here, equivalent to going from an ant to a
brontosaurus, if that maybe means more to
you.
And we don't even have the virus.
The virus would be sitting on top of that
bacteria.
So these were all of the organisms that we
wanted to study in the Tara Oceans expedition.
It had never been done sort of from end-to-end
before.
So it was a challenge to put together protocols
to sample all of those organisms.
And we also wanted to do this on a worldwide
scale, because the ocean is one.
It's a single ecosystem.
But to understand that ecosystem, you have
to sample it globally.
So we performed this four-year expedition
that is summarized on the slide here, where
you see in 2009, we left France.
We went through the Mediterranean, through
the Red Sea, down the Indian Ocean, across
the South Atlantic, into the Southern Ocean
in Antarctica, and then went out the South
Pacific towards Tahiti, up to Hawaii, back
to San Diego, through the Panama Canal, up
to New York, and back to France, over three
years.
And then in 2013, we performed a second expedition,
going around the Arctic Circle up here, because
the Tara sailboat is able to withstand the
ice, able to withstand the pressures of the
ice, and is able to be able to do that sort
of extreme expedition quite aptly.
So during this summer season here, took us
six months to get around first the Northeast
Passage of Russia and then through the Northwest
Passage above Canada.
Many explorers have lost their lives looking
for those passages in the past.
But these days, it's possible to get through,
because of the melting ice up in the Arctic.
But Tara is, anyhow, the first sailboat to
have gotten through both Northeast and Northwest
Passages in one season.
So during this whole campaign, we sampled
at all these different sampling points that
you see here marked out on the map.
Our objective was really to do the same thing
wherever we went, so that ultimately we could
compare samples that we got in Antarctica
with samples that we got in the Arctic, for
example.
So there's a lot of mundane work to really
generate high quality samples that would allow
us to subsequently compare sort of everything
with everything.
So at the end of this whole adventure, we
had sampled at 210 different sampling sites
around the global ocean.
And we brought back 40,000 samples to the
labs involved in the Tara Oceans project for
subsequent analysis.
We brought back other data sets, other samples,
which were also useful for some of the analyses
we wanted to do afterwards.
So that's when the real hard work begins,
to dig through these 40,000 samples and try
to make some sense out of them.
And we were very happy that we were able to
describe the first foundational results from
the project in a special issue of Science
that was published almost two years ago now,
on May 22, 2015.
And in the special issue of Science, we were
able to publish five papers back-to-back,
describing the foundational results from the
project.
We got the editorial.
We got the front cover.
We got a lot of coverage in the scientific
press and also in the daily press.
We got also the front page of The New York
Times.
This is their view of plankton, not exactly
microscopic, but at least it serves to get
the message across.
So we're very happy to create this splash
of media coverage finally about plankton.
And just let me show you briefly what is contained
in some of those papers in Science.
In one of those papers, we described what
we call the ocean microbiome.
So you've maybe heard of the human microbiome,
the microbes that live on human beings.
In this paper, we described the equivalent
for the ocean, the microbes that live in the
ocean, in particular the bacteria.
We described this microbiome from 68 sampling
sites within our data-set, so we had pretty
good global coverage of the global ocean.
And within this microbiome, we described 40
million different genes.
That is close to saturation, so this is pretty
much all of the genes that are present in
bacteria in the ocean, at least in the top
100 meters or so of the water column.
So it's a huge resource that is now publicly
available that is being used by scientists
worldwide.
This is about 30,000 times more sequence than
was generated by a certain Craig Venter in
a similar expedition performed several years
before us.
And of these 40 million genes, you can imagine
most of them are new to science.
More than 80% of them were discovered on the
Tara Oceans expedition.
And the vast majority of them we don't know
what their functions are.
So there's a lot of discovery to be done to
try to understand what those functions are.
So that was one paper.
In another paper, we described the ocean virome,
the collection of viruses that we could find
in the ocean by methods that I won't go into.
But in this paper, we described 5 and 1/2
thousand different kinds of viruses in the
global ocean.
Prior to Tara Oceans, only 39 were previously
known.
So that gives you, again, an idea of the incredible
rate of discovery coming from the project.
And then, for these protists, the unicellular
eukaryotes, this gets a bit more complicated,
because we have an incredible diversity of
organisms within the eukaryotic tree of life
that is shown here, for many of which we have
no cultured representatives.
We don't know what they look like.
And there's an incredible unexplored diversity
that we know very little about.
To give you an idea, within this tree of life
here, we are sitting here within the animals.
And the closest branch to us are the sponges.
So here we've got animals and sponges.
And then beyond animals and sponges, you have
all this incredible diversity of organisms
that we know very little about.
So from this survey of these protists, what
we described in one of these papers was about
130,000 genetic types.
Let's not call them species, but sort of species.
130,000 different kinds of eukaryotes in the
ocean.
Again, this is saturating, so we've more or
less found everything that is there.
So if you give me another sample of sea water,
we'll more or less just find what we've already
found from this project here.
And again, there's an incredible novelty represented
in this data-set.
This represents more than 10 times the number
of formerly described species of marine eukaryotic
plankton.
So 90% are new.
And about a third of them, we cannot assign
them to any known taxonomic group within this
tree of life.
So whether these organisms represent very
primitive groups sort of at the center of
eukaryotic diversity remains to be seen.
But there's an incredible amount of diversity
that was revealed here.
Now all of this was done by DNA sequencing,
very, very high-throughput throughput DNA
sequencing, which gives you a one-dimensional
string of Gs, As, Ts, and Cs.
It doesn't really necessarily tell you what
these organisms are.
So it's very, very important to try to associate
some sort of morphology, some sort of shapes,
some sort of forms with those DNA sequences.
And so that is why we developed additional
protocols to perform automated, high-content
imaging of these organisms sitting on specialized
microscopes we call confocal microscopes,
such that we can get these very, very detailed
views of what individual kinds of planktonic
organisms look like.
Here are a couple of examples in more detail.
So using these different kinds of fluorescent
dyes, we can look at the exoskeletons of these
organisms.
We can look inside these cells as well.
This is dye in a flagellate inside.
The red is a chloroplast.
The green are membranes sitting inside the
cell.
This is about a hundredth of a millimeter
in size.
This organism is a diatom, which is a glass
silica cell wall.
You can see how elaborate that is in light
blue here.
Going inside the cell, we can see the chloroplast
in red.
The DNA is sitting inside the nucleus here
in blue in this very elongated vesicle here.
So we have all kinds of shapes of these organisms.
We have more than a million of these kinds
of images.
And we're now trying to associate the DNA
sequences with these morphological information
to try to figure out who is who.
That's obviously a work in progress that is
going to take some time.
So now that I've sort of described to you
what we know about the bacterial components,
what we know about the virus components, what
we know about the protist components in the
ocean, we can take all of that data.
We can throw it all together.
We have that information from 68 different
locations around the ocean.
We can throw all of that data together.
And we can ask, well, who lives with who?
Who is found in the same location as the other
organisms?
Or who is never found with other organisms?
So through this very large compute, we can
define what we call in technical terms the
interactome of the plankton ecosystems.
You can also consider this a social network
of the ocean, the ocean's Facebook.
So this took several months to compute.
It's not particularly nice how it looks in
the end.
But this is the plankton interactome here.
The different dots are different kinds of
organisms.
And the lines between organisms are either
associations in green, so organisms that co-occur,
that live in the same place.
Or in red, organisms that tend to exclude
other organisms.
So you can see some patterns in here.
You can see some kinds of plankton that are
sort of universally excluding other organisms,
so universally anti-social.
We can consider these as the Putins, the Donald
Trumps of the plankton world that are very,
very strongly negative.
We've also got these very positive guys, the
universally sort of green.
These would be the Tom Bradys, at least in
isolated communities, the Beyonces, Lady Gagas,
and so on.
So we have all these kinds of different plankton,
which we can tease apart and try to understand
more about what they're actually doing.
The sorts of conclusions that come out from
this work is that, on the one hand, biotic
interactions are more important than abiotic
interactions, which basically means it's more
important who you live with than where you
live.
That was one important conclusion that we
were kind of surprised to see.
And then the other conclusion if we prize
apart the positive associations, the organisms
that live with each other, and compare them
against organisms that never live with each
other, the sort of positive and the negative
associations, we see quite strikingly that
the number of positive associations are more
than three times higher than the negative,
sort of telling us that corporation appears
be more important than competition in these
ecosystems, which was quite a surprise to
us when we caught this signal.
We always think of evolution as being competition,
survival of the fittest, who is strongest
outcompetes the others.
But in fact, no, the message of the plankton
world is more telling us that it's all about
cooperation, working together to ensure that
the ecosystem together works that is more
important than trying to screw your neighbor
and so on.
So that is an interesting message that we
got out of that study.
And then, when we look at these interactions,
we look at these communities.
I mean, this is complex, but don't worry.
But when we look at the communities of these
different kinds of plankton, and we see what
determines who is present together in a particular
environment, we see that it's very much temperature
that is the main environmental driver determining
what the community structure looks like.
So basically, what that means, if you give
me a sample of seawater, and I look at the
community of organisms that is present in
there, I can tell you with pretty good degree
of certainty the temperature of that seawater.
So it's a very sophisticated thermometer that
we have found here.
But that's not really the point.
The point is that these organisms, even the
microscopic organisms, are exquisitely sensitive
to temperature, which brings us back to the
issue of today's ocean being very much under
pressure by these increased temperatures that
are happening as a consequence of global warming.
So this really leads us to realize that we
really have to understand how these organisms
are going to change, are going to migrate,
or are going to adapt as a consequence of
changing temperatures in the ocean in future
years.
And We have quite some information about that,
thanks to the work of the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change, the IPCC, who have
done a lot of work bringing a lot of data
together to generate models about how the
future Earth is going to look in the years
to come.
And what I'm going to show you here is a video
that begins in 1950, showing how temperature
has changed on the surface of the Earth up
until today, and how it's projected to change
up until the year 2100.
And this is a pretty conservative model.
It's based on pretty reasonable emissions
of carbon dioxide in years to come.
And what you're going to see is changes in
temperature I've revealed by warmer colors
showing increasing temperatures or bluer,
cooler colors as cooling events.
So let's see if that starts.
Here we go.
So you see this moving.
We're in 1960.
You see it's going pretty quickly.
And these are sort of temperature anomalies,
as some regions get a bit redder or a bit
bluer.
Everything is moving around fairly insignificantly,
up until now.
We're getting through to where we are today.
And we can see how much the Arctic is really
suffering from increased temperatures.
Here we're going into the future.
So this is a model simulation, based on the
best available science today.
And you can see how the Arctic, in particular,
is affected.
We can see the Tibetan Plateau loses its glaciers
fairly soon.
And by the end of the century, things are
not looking very good at all.
So this really raises the importance of trying
to raise the alarm bells, if you like.
Our signal from the plankton world about their
sensitivity to temperature really made us
realize that we really have to get the message
across from the science about the state that
we're actually in.
So we used the climate convention, the climate
conference in Paris in 2015 as a moment to
mobilize the troops, to bring everybody together,
and create what we called the Ocean Climate
Platform that was created in 2015 and continues
to exist today.
And this brings together all kinds of different
players with interests in the ocean.
Some of these you will recognize, like Scripps,
the Smithsonian, the Pew Trust, various others
from the US.
It's very much an international operation.
And the idea was to forget about the individual
interests of the different organizations,
the different NGOs who may be interested in
plastic pollution or extension of marine protected
areas or whatever.
The idea was basically to forget about the
individual interests of each of these groups
and just come together and promote one single
voice at the climate conference in Paris,
which was simply to give a voice to the ocean,
very, very simply.
And we managed to do that.
We organized an Ocean Day during the climate
conference in Paris.
We brought together a lot of very important
people.
Here, you see-- that's Irina Bokova from UNESCO.
That's Prince Albert of Monaco.
And we're all talking the same voice of giving
the oceans a voice.
Sylvia Earle was with us.
Al Gore was with us.
Tara came into Paris.
Ban Ki-moon came to visit us.
All together to give the ocean a voice.
And incredibly, we succeeded for the first
time.
We succeeded to get the oceans mentioned in
the climate convention, the climate agreement
that was signed in Paris last year.
It's a very minor mention.
It's just in the preamble.
But you'll see here-- this is what is mentioned,
noting the importance of ensuring the integrity
of all ecosystems, including oceans and the
protection of biodiversity, recognized by
some cultures as Mother Earth.
This is COP 21.
So it took 21 years to get the ocean into
the agenda, into the climate agenda.
It's incredible to realize that it took so
long to give the oceans a voice at this high
political level.
But we're very happy that working together,
sort of getting inspiration from how the plankton
were cooperating, rather than competing, that
we managed collectively to raise the voice
of the ocean and make it part of the climate
convention.
So this is really just the start of a journey.
I tried to show you some of the science that
has been generated from the Tara Oceans project
that is continuing, fast forward very much.
I showed you how we're able to try to influence
the political, the regulatory situation through
the science, through the voice of science.
We try to transmit the science that we're
doing through cultural initiatives, through
artists in residence that we have on board
that produce different kinds of works of art
that talk about plankton, that talk about
the oceans, and so on.
And then moving forward, in the future, we
expect that the science will lead us through
to an increased understanding of how the ocean
works, to improve our models of what the ocean
is going to look like in the future, to predict
our predictive power, and how to respond to
the changes that are actually underway in
this moment, either through intervention,
through remediation, or through prevention,
if we're lucky enough to be able to do that.
And then, finally, there are all kinds of
ways in which this data, this knowledge can
be exploited through biodiscovery, through
bioengineering, discovery of new kinds of
genes with new kinds of functions for biomedical,
industrial applications, and so on.
So this is a summary as we move forward.
So let me end there, and let me thank the
people behind this project.
It's been very much a collective effort.
A lot of people, our sponsors, who provided
the money for the expedition, and research
agencies for the science.
We're about 20 partners, scientific partners
in the project.
MIT is part of it.
NASA is part of it in the US.
University of Arizona.
And so thank you to them for their commitment
to this project.
And thank you to you for your attention.